und jetzt seht ihr mal was passiert wenn
ich damit gegen einen ender drachen
schlage der ist einfach direkt tot
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge der
minecraft commands heute donnerstag ist
heute glaube ich dass man sorry das ich
gestern versprochen habe dass noch ein
fragt luca video kommt und ich kann auch
noch nicht versprechen dass morgen
wirklich die packs kommen weil ich
derzeit in der klausurphase bin mega
viel von morgens bis abends mit lärm
beschäftigt bin und youtube da ehrlich
wirklich gesagt einfach zu kurz kommen
es tut mir leid die klausurphase
nächsten mittwoch vorbei und ab da
kommen dann wieder regelmäßig videos ich
denke ich werde morgen schaffen defekts
hochzuladen nur wahrscheinlich erst ein
bisschen später morgen abend oder so und
ich würde einfach wieder sagen ich habe
wieder richtig coole commands dabei also
ich finde die command echt in jeder
folge mal richtig geil und dann solchen
command sollte man sich echt ein
beispiel nehmen wenn man mir kommen zu
sein dann von der kreativität der weil
die sind richtig geil dickes dicke props
an alle die mir die komatsu gesendet
haben und ich würd sagen wir fangen
direkt ankommen hat nummer gefragt warum
ich hier so ein crazy band um meinen
kopf habe das ist einfach nur alt hat es
ist schon krass diese ganze welt diese
lange hälse sieht einfach aus ist wäre
ja alles mögliche eigene schlage ich
habe heute sondern ich weiß nicht wie
das beauty youtuber sagen würde bad hair
day oder irgendwie so also meine haare
gehen heute einfach gar nicht und ich
hab halt wie gesagt den ganztag bisher
nur gelernt und nicht duschen sie
möglicherweise scheitern wir fangen erst
mal mit commander mainz mir zugesagt
wurde von lego meister und zwar kann man
damit seinen tod vortäuscht wenn man das
hier ein gibt man kann einfach eingeben
schrägstrich leerzeichen und dann
irgendein text bewusst lane bei zombie
beispielsweise dann kommt ein text sein
eigener name moslems haben die wir
können auch einfach schreiben nie los
lane bei will dildo hand hahn ich kann
ich schreiben ich kann nicht lesen will
do hunter 007 drei ausrufezeichen dann
kommt das hier im chat und damit kann
man rein theoretisch auch wirklich wenn
ihr auf servern sein oder so könnt ihr
einfach so schreiben wenn kumpel da seid
ihr könnt ihr einfach den markt rollen
und so sagen hey ich bin dem kampf im
zolli ich habe alle die rücken dabei und
dann kommt das einem chat einfach
kompakter moslem als hobby kann ich
schwören neun von zehn minecraft wir uns
an als ob du gestorben willst du
eigentlich
so der erfahrene minecraft spieler der
fahne hase wird natürlich sagen oh allah
ist von sternchen vor ort so eingegeben
und so aber damit kann man auf jeden
fall erstmal seinen tod vortäuschen ich
weiß immer noch nicht woher diese weise
hier kommt weiß nicht ob sich irgendwann
fragt warum wir hier im netz sind aber
das hat irgendwas mit diesem
themenbereich das ganze interessant weil
das so eine kleine nebensache von diesem
effekt ist und zwar erst mal wurde mir
ich sag dem effekt dass es eigentlich
ein kommando wurde von tsk 08 zugesendet
das ist ein durchdrehende ender dragon
also ich muss das hier eingeben
schrägstrich sammeln also ich erschaffe
einen ender dragon mit den drei wellen
also da wo ich mich gerade befinde
riding geändert ist also bereitet einen
ender kristall und der ändern kristall
ist eher so eine art entity mehr oder
weniger und das heißt dass er quasi an
dieses alter der rastet der richter ist
jetzt quasi so an diese länder christine
gebunden alter der ja ich habe richtig
angst vor dem sex tape erklärt der
eskalierte ja richtig jedenfalls wird er
sich unbedingt davon lösen aber damit
irgendwie man davon angezogen und hat
dementsprechend online energiequelle dar
und das krasse ist jetzt also die damit
könnte quasi zum ende drachen erschaffen
der immer auf einer stelle bei euch in
der map quasi haust und da einfach so
kam eskalierte okay ich wollte euch
jetzt eigentlich was zeigen aber der
ender drache hat ja ach es kaputt
gemacht ich versuche jetzt nochmal zu
zeigen und zwar für den ändert rachen
und die tatsache ist einfach wenn ich
jetzt dieses ding zerstöre rastet der
einfach noch mal völlig aus so macht er
einfach alles kaputt fliegt alles um und
fliegt danach einfach ganz weit weg
normalerweise würde der sicher danach
neun länder kristall suchen aber da hier
kein findet ist er dann einfach mega
verwirrt also ihr seht dass der rastet
hier richtig aus der fliegt einfach weg
jetzt der wieder in die andere richtung
jetzt liegt eher in die richtung und der
sitzt jetzt quasi zu den nächsten ändern
küste um wieder energie zu kriegen dann
geht der teilweise auch wieder auf mich
jetzt hier um mich dann irgendwie zu
versuchen anzugreifen und da irgendwie
sowas also damit kann man auf jeden fall
erstmal wenn ich das hier eingeben ender
drachen machen der immer an dieses ding
gehalten ist das könnt ihr machen wenn
ihr beispielsweise keine ahnung ob
museum machen wollte den ender drachen
daran halten wollte und dass der andere
kristalle mit dem anderen verbunden das
ist natürlich sehr damit könnt ihr auf
jeden fall so einander drachen fesseln
einfach mit dem command und den findet
ihr natürlich auch in der beschreibung
wenige richtet silber machen schauen
wollte und dann kommen wir jetzt unsere
nummer drei ist eine recht simple sache
aber eine sache die einfach so geil es
die ist unfassbar cool also ich weiß
nicht warum ich mich für so einfache
sachen immer
krass faszinieren kann oder so aber ich
finde es halt richtig geil und zwar
sendet mir die dominik glaube ich ich
glaube du bist eine die weil sonst
würdest du dominik heiß und das ist es
aber egal man kann damit die text farbe
ändern und zwar gebe ich jetzt mal
diesen text enthält alle text hallo welt
color yellow und jetzt ist dieser text
hallo hallo welt ich kann jetzt
natürlich auch die mal was anderes
eingeben beispielsweise ich gebe da
einfach mal dildo hunter 007 ein und wie
farbe kann ich jetzt auch mal rein
theoretisch zu blue ändern und dann
sehen wir da steht jetzt dildo hunter
007 in blau also damit könnt ihr quasi
genau das gleiche in den text schreiben
nur mit einer anderen farbe ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob das auch mit etwas und
so funktioniert eigentlich könnten wir
das ja eben hat es ok freunde wir
befinden uns jetzt in einer runde etwas
und ich finde allgemein dafür dass ich
das schon mal jetzt gemacht habe hier um
hier in runde drei zu kommen könnt ihr
mal die dunkle ob drücke ich möchte
nicht betteln aber dich meinen diese
serie ist einfach so viel arbeit ich die
serien von anderen youtube und da habe
ich natürlich nichts gegen aber ich
mache mir einfach schon mega viel arbeit
und ich will auch gar nicht vergesst es
gibt keinen daumen testen das ganze ist
allerdings mal und zwar gebe ich das
jetzt einfach mal ein dj lord have
permission to performance ist kummer und
ok also wenn ich das beispielsweise
sensoren wie survival games oder
irgendwie in bad gastein gebe habe keine
vermischen das einzugeben
also in irgend einer anderen farbe zu
schreiben kann ich auch ehrlich gesagt
verstehen weil man damit andere spieler
ablenken könnte oder man könnte
theoretisch in grünen schreiben obwohl
man in team gelb ist oder so und dann
wäre natürlich ein geldeinnahme auch
noch im team gelbmann können grün
schreiben das könnte verwirren und man
könnte links hervorheben und was weiß
ich alles das ist schon ein ganz coole
sache das ist eigentlich nicht gehen
aber im zweifel geht und da bieten wir
uns jetzt auch wieder hin
ich hoffe da ist jetzt nichts passiert
von wegen frei
dafür dass nichts passiert von wegen
frame einbrüche oder erzeugen wie sowas
weil immer wenn man server wechselt und
dann wieder auf singer reingeht und so
brechen die frames kurzem betreibt ist
auch egal jedenfalls wurde mir kommen
vier zugesendet von detonator
unterstrich 2001 und zwar kann man damit
einen vulkan schaffen das ist dieser
command den geben wir allerdings
sicherheit sondern was wir erstmal
eingeben ist / xp command unterstrich
blog damit wir einen command block
erhalten ich finde immer noch darum dass
man ihn nicht im inventar irgendwie
kriegen kann und was wir uns noch holen
müssen ist ein redstone block und zwar
geben jetzt erstmal hier den kommunen
also dieser command ist das einfachste
blog da auf der stelle +1 die koordinate
das haben ja viele jetzt gesagt dass ich
auch einfach anstatt die zahl anzugeben
bei dem aufzug ihrer letzten folge ich
auch einfach da eine eins hinter
schreiben können oder 04 dann wäre das
einfach vier etagen höher von der block
anzahl ein kräfte redstone blog 0 die
story dass er andere zerstört wenn die
da sind und wenn ich den jetzt darauf
setzte wird ist erst mal kurz mechanik
die jetzt passiert hier ist dieser
command block der sport jetzt immer
einen redstone blog da oben allerdings
ist da schon einer und aufgrund dieser
destroy sache wird er oben quasi
zerstört und durch einen neuen ersetzt
und deswegen fällt ja immer ein rätsel
blog darunter wieder runter mehr oder
weniger und deswegen erschafft sich da
immer dadurch dass der rezeptor blocker
immer gepaart ist er schafft sich ein
red storm block und der ist wieder
gebaut und dadurch erschafft sich wieder
ein red sox versteht ihr fast ich machen
wenn ich mal rein theoretisch was in
städten gebe wie beispielsweise hallo
seht ihr jetzt mal wie schnell diese
blogs bond mein hallo ist einfach direkt
verschwunden nicht das ganze jetzt hier
quasi noch so ein bisschen ein bündel
dass man in command locken ich sieht
hätte ich quasi hiermit jetzt so einen
vulkan in minecraft dargestellt dass auf
jeden fall eine mega coole sache wenn
ich mal meine inventar gucke ich bin
schon nahezu komplett voll mit rap song
blöcke ich kann mich auch einfach mal
hier hinstellen damit ihr seht wie
schnell die quasi hier die ganze
aufgefüllt werden oder wenn ich mal hier
wieder kurz lang laufen wird die hier
schon wieder ein stück mehr
da laufe ich hier mal eben kurz kommen
und dann sehe ich hier schon wieder um
viele anderthalb sechs mehr
er ist auf jeden fall richtig krass wenn
ich ihn richtig cooler command wenn man
nimmt sondern welt mit lokal machen
möchte wie das auf jeden fall recht teil
aus man müsste das dann irgendwie aus
dem chat entfernen noch mitbekommen hat
dass es nicht angezeigt mit dem chat
aber dass auf jeden fall erstmal richtig
gute sache die wir zu seite wurde von
beeten nato 2001 dieser command wurde
mir zugesendet von zoran lp und zwar es
ist einfach das krasseste schwert und
damit kann man einander drachen mit
einem hit töten habe den command hier
schon ein gegeben da seht ihr den euro
jetzt aus diesem winter gemacht ihr seht
ihr jedenfalls schon den kopf
command und ich baue jetzt hier einfach
mal um euch das zu demonstrieren diese
sache die wir vorher schon hatten uns
zwar in ender dragon deswegen baut
dieser fällt quasi auf dem zweiten
effekt auf drücke jetzt einfach mal hier
und habe jetzt einen diamant schwert mit
diesen effekten und jetzt seht ihr mal
was passiert wenn ich damit gegen einen
ender drachen schlage der ist einfach
direkt tot also damit kann man einen
ender drachen direkt töten ich könnte
mal rein theoretisch hier hakt und der
flieger so zehn milliarden jahre weg
sagt hakt oder heizöl so richtig krasse
schwert einfach das hat die krassesten
verzauberung ich weiß es sehr und
kreativ aber ich find's einfach witzig
weil man da wird einfach so denkt was du
machst verpasst
das heißt du gegen meine mutter gesagt
neben gerd ich weiß nicht was mit mir
los ist ich glaube ich leider einfach
einschlafen ich hatte die letzten zwei
wochen nie länger als vier stunden
schlaf glaube ich oder ich hab schon
wieder verdrängt wenn ich mal länger
geschlafen habe oder hab gedacht ich
werde wach gewesen aber denke ich ist ja
auch egal dass wir auf jeden fall
erstmal weg nummer fünf damit so
gesendet wurde von zoran lp und damit
war's das auch schon wieder für die
heutige folge der minecraft kommen wenn
es euch gefallen hat es ist ein klick
ich würde mich über eine bewertung
freuen weil es eine menge arbeit ist und
ich schon in einer stunde wieder in die
uni bibliothek nun muss noch lernen und
ich muss auch die farbe egal ich möchte
nicht zu viel verraten aber ich bin auf
jeden fall zurzeit hinter den kulissen
ganz vieler machen was meine bildung
angeht das hört sich irgendwie falsch
jedenfalls war es dass das jetzt mit den
minecraft commands und ich würde sorgen
wir sehen uns am morgen bei den fans
wieder wenn ich die denn schaffe morgen
und dann würde ich sagen
[Musik]